[Musik]
stell dir vor es würde plötzlich für
milliarden von menschen das licht
ausgehen
aus der steckdose kommt kein strom mehr
die leitungen liegen still und das nicht
nur für ein paar stunden sondern für
monate oder sogar jahre
von jetzt auf gleich mittelalter das
klingt wie ein historischer film
die folgen wären katastrophal viele
kommunikationswege wären tot
die wasserversorgung wurde nicht mehr
funktionieren der transport von
nahrungsmitteln medizin und anderen
wichtigen gütern wurde mit der zeit
immer schwieriger werden
unsere heutige gesellschaft kann ohne
strom einfach nicht mehr funktionieren
aber was wenn ich euch sage dass so ein
katastrophaler blackout zu jeder sekunde
passieren kann und wie auf die folgen so
gut wie gar nicht vorbereitet sind
[Musik]
dieses video wurde durch cam wie
ermöglicht camping erlaubt es euch mit
tutoren aus aller welt zu sprechen und
so einfach englisch zu lernen
wie das genau funktioniert erkläre ich
euch am ende des videos
sie spendet wärme und energie und unsere
uhren richten sich nach ihrem aufwand
integrieren ohne die sonne wäre leben
auf der erde gar nicht erst entstanden
all diese positiven eigenschaften
verbergen aber eine dunkle seite
oder vielmehr einige dunkle flecken denn
unter anderem von diesen sogenannten
sonnenflecken geht eine
unwahrscheinliche aber sehr große gefahr
aus im expertenkreis wird es als
ereignis mit geringer wahrscheinlichkeit
und hoher konsequenz bezeichnet
die rede ist von starken sonnenstürmen
ihren ursprung finden diese stürme in
sonneneruptionen welche sich eben vor
allem in gebieten von sonnen fackeln und
flecken zeigen in form einer gewaltigen
stark strahlenden masse geladene
partikel reichen diese sonneneruptionen
bis in die krone sphäre
das ist eine dicke eisschicht oberhalb
der sonnenoberfläche wirklich schlimm
ist eine solche sonneneruptionen aber
nicht unbedingt
es gibt nämlich zwei arten die harmlose
variante ist die so genannte homo
sphärische eruption bei welcher die
austretende masse lediglich in einem
sehr hohen bogen wieder zurück zur
sonnenoberfläche fliegt problematisch
wird es erst bei der zweiten form beim
sogenannten koronalen massenauswurf hier
bildet sich zwar ein ähnlicher bogen nur
bricht dieser irgendwann ab wodurch sich
das plasma von der sonne löst und ins
all geschleudert wird
diese riesige menge an geladenen
partikeln wird dann auch noch durch den
sonnenwind verteilt das erhöht die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass die erde davon
getroffen wird und wenn das passieren
sollte dann kriegen wir hier auf der
erde ein großes problem denn dann wird
ein sogenannter geomagnetische sturm
ausgelöst während eines solchen magnet
sturms wird das magnetfeld der erde
geschwächt
die jahre verliert ihre natürliche
schutzschicht jegliche strahlung aus dem
all hat dann plötzlich mehr oder weniger
frei bahn zur erde
glücklicherweise wurde der sturm selbst
wahrscheinlich nur um die zwei tage
andauern
danach kann sich das magnetfeld
innerhalb von ein paar tagen wieder
aufbauen
tatsächlich werden wir circa alle 15
jahre
von kleineren eruptionen getroffen deren
konsequenzen aber nicht wirklich fatal
wird je größer eine eruption jedoch ist
je mehr plasma also auf die erde treffen
kann desto verheerender können die
auswirkungen werden
bei einer besonders großen
sonneneruptionen oder im fall von
mehreren gleichzeitigen eruptionen
könnte es aber zu einem hilfe
die konsequenzen dieser eruptionen und
des daraus resultierenden magnet sturms
sind vielfältig zum beispiel bekommen
besonders die polarregionen eine erhöhte
ladung kosmischer strahlung ab auch
fühlt sich plötzlich der nachthimmel
selbst im niedrigen breitengraden mit
polarlichter eine konsequenz der
geschwächten magnetosphäre für uns
menschen ist aber die wohl
problematischste folge die großflächige
beschädigung unseres stromnetzes denn
der sturm würde geomagnetische
induzierte ströme auslösen
diese ströme kann man sich als
zusätzlicher elektrizität vorstellen die
plötzlich durch unsere leitungen fließt
das problem mit diesem strömen ist dass
unser stromnetz nicht für eine solche
last gebaut wurde
zentraler bestandteil jeder stromleitung
ist ein sogenannter leistungs
transformator das ist eine art
schnittstelle die hohe spannungen zum
beispiel aus der produktion in geringere
allgemein nutzbare spannung für zuhause
umwandelt und genau diese
transformatoren kommen nicht mit der
plötzlich erhöhten stromstärke klar und
können letzten endes sogar schmelzen
genau das ist 1989 schon einmal
geschehen als es in kanada einen
kleineren magnet sturm gab aber bevor
wir hier auf der erdoberfläche überhaupt
etwas bemerken können richtet diese
welle an geladenen partikeln bereits
schwere schäden über unseren köpfen an
unsere satelliten bekommen immerhin die
ungerechte wucht dieser sonneneruption
ab auch hier treten induzierte ströme
auf die alles von kurzschlüssen bis zu
geschmolzenen transformatoren
hervorrufen können satelliten in einer
niedrigen umlaufbahn sind aber auch noch
von einer anderen konsequenz betroffen
die schockwelle kann die erdatmosphäre
aufheizen und verformen wodurch sich der
atmosphärische widerstand dieser tiefer
fliegenden satelliten erhöht und sie im
schlimmsten fall zurück zur erde fallen
es würden schäden in milliarden höhe
entstehen
gps satelliten internet und viele
wichtige forschungsprojekte alle
verloren
die wirklichen probleme fangen aber
gerade erst an
mit den meisten transformatoren zerstört
stehen wer zu einem globalen
stromausfall und das nicht nur für ein
paar tage sondern für wochen monate oder
im schlimmsten fall jahre um das netz
wieder zu reparieren wird man
transformatoren brauchen und die stehen
nicht massenweise rum und warten darauf
dass der nächste sonnensturm
alleine das austauschen der
transformatoren kann monate dauern und
noch einmal milliarden kosten
denn welche fabrik kann heutzutage ohne
strom funktionieren
eine zwickmühle in der zwischenzeit
würden lebens erhaltungsmaßnahmen in
krankenhäusern ausfallen
einfach weil ein notstromaggregat benzin
oder diesel benötigt welche ohne strom
auch nicht mehr produziert werden können
ein ähnliches problem haben dann auch
kernkraftwerke und chemischen anlagen
die ebenfalls plötzlich auf notstrom
angewiesen sind um gefährliche
substanzen zu kontrollieren wasser
punkten und co stehen irgendwann still
wodurch wasser und nahrungsversorgung
sehr viel schwieriger werden könnten
dazu kommt dann auch noch der
zusammenbruch globaler kommunikation und
ein daraus resultierender börsencrash
die welt befindet sich von einem tag auf
den anderen im absoluten ausnahmezustand
okay das klingt alles nach einem
schrecklichen horrorszenario wie können
wir uns davor schützen
na ja einer der ersten gedanken ist
natürlich alle anfälligen bereiche des
stromnetzes gegenstrom induktion zu
schützen
salat stürme sind nämlich ein bekanntes
problem in der elektroindustrie
bisher wurde dieses problem aber nur bei
größer gebauten einrichtungen gelöst
welche die induzierten ströme besser
verteilen und ableiten konnten die
kosten wären allerdings bereits kaum
vertretbar wenn wir diese taktik nur auf
die strategisch wichtigsten
transformatoren anwenden würden
und selbst dann würde diese methode
keinen garantierten schutz gegen extrem
starke störungen gebieten auch die
option einfach ersatzteile im überfluss
zu lagern wäre etwas unsinnig das würde
zu viel geld kosten und gleichzeitig das
größte problem gar nicht lösen
einige wichtige sektoren hätten erstmal
monate lang keinen strom
es dauert eben auch zeit die
transformatoren zu liefern und
einzubauen
es gibt aber zum glück eine sinnvollere
lösung mit hilfe von satelliten und
teleskopen können wir die sonne und ihre
flecken beobachten und so eine art
frühwarnsystem entwickeln heutige
technologien ermöglichen uns bereits
eine warnung bis zu 24 stunden vor dem
eintreffen eines sonnensturms
dieser zeitraum ermöglicht uns gesamte
stromnetze im vorhinein abzuschalten
sind die transformatoren vom stromnetz
getrennt können sie auch nicht überladen
werden und schmelzen
da so etwas aber großflächige
kooperationen beanspruchen würde ist das
natürlich einfacher gesagt als getan
das chaos in diesen 24 stunden vor dem
magnet sturm wäre riesig menschen sind
aufgebracht versuchen aus den städten
zufrieden oder sogar aus der situation
profit zu schlagen
letztendlich wäre das abschalten der
stromnetze aber die billigste und
einfachste option in kombination mit
schutztechnologien für beispielsweise
atomkraftwerke und krankenhäuser könnte
dieser sonnensturm kommen es gibt also
selbst für überwältigende ereignisse aus
dem weltall echte lösungswege ein
hundertprozentig vorbereitet sind wir
zwar noch nicht aber die realität ist
glücklicherweise immer noch etwas
langweiliger als dystopische horrorfilme
wenn ich videos wie dieses jahres ihre
dann verwende ich zu einem großen teil
quellen auf englisch das geht fast gar
nicht anders denn englisch ist die
international anerkannte sprache für
wissenschaft und forschung und es stehen
mir so gefühlt zehn mal mehr webseiten
zur verfügung wenn ihr euer englisch
verbessern volt geht das am besten indem
man regelmäßig englisch spricht
kempny ist eine app mit der ihr 24
stunden am tag mit tutoren aus aller
welt verbunden wertet und mit ihnen
englisch sprechen können
die touren sind in meiner erfahrung alle
super netz und können auch auf
individuelle wünsche eingehen
ob einfach nur um entsprechend drin zu
bleiben als hilfe bei den hausaufgaben
oder als training für einen bestimmten
test eine session kann nur 15 minuten
lang sein so dass man immer mal ein
kleines training dazwischen schieben
kann
und wenn man sich an eine bestimmte
lektion erinnern will kennedy zeichnet
alle gespräche optional auf wenn ihr den
link unten in der video beschreibung
benutzt dann könnt ihr die app 15
minuten lang kostenlos testen und beim
kauf eines abos zehn prozent sparen
in der app müsst ihr dafür diesen code
eingeben danke ein camp für die
unterstützung bei diesem video und an
euch vielen dank fürs zuschauern bleibt
neugierig
[Musik]